- Ah, double trouble, here we go.
- Okay, serious question,
who's the Tia, who's the Tamera?
You're Tia for sure.
- Oh my gosh, twins.
Oh my gosh, twins.
- Oh my gosh.
- Can you guys read each other's minds?
- Can your family tell you apart?
- Do you guys do everything together?
- Uh, personal question,
which one of you came out first?
- Happy birthday guys, I got you cupcakes.
Twins! Happy birthday.
- I'm a vegan.
- It's not our birthday.
- Hey Keith, it's 9:15,
where's your brother?
- I don't know.
- Well I need you two to
take this job seriously,
you can't be late.
- Can you please not--
- Nope.
- Wait, you're Kenny and you're Keith?
- You're Keith, you're Kenny.
- Hey Keith.
Last night was amazing,
like I can't stop thinking about it.
That thing in the swing, and
then when we did it backwards
I was just like oh my gosh yes,
we need to do that more.
Oh God.
- Okay, stop it.
- But you're fun size, I wanna touch--
- Yo fool she said stop man.
- I'm sorry man.
- Hey dude, chill out.
- Oh my gosh, you guys are
even more adorable than she is.
You're like the dynamic duo.
- Yo Keith dude, don't forget
about my party tonight.
- I'll be there man.
- I'm glad, it's gonna be huge.
- It's gonna be dope right?
- Oh yeah, yeah man.
I don't think we got
enough room for everybody.
- This is crazy.
- Maybe we'll be elected for president.
- That'd be dope.
- We'd be twin presidents.
That's never happened before.
- I believe it.